I've been seeing a lot of people's diversity statements,
and I really,
just quickly
want to make sure that I help you guys understand
what has to be in your diversity statement.
and your diversity statement and your personal
statement are different for a couple reasons.
your personal statement has to tell me why you're
applying to law school.
it has to tell me what makes you a strong student,
has to give me some background on you
and what got you to your decision to go to law school.
your diversity statement is different
because you need to define what is making you diverse.
so I see a lot of times where people just, like,
describe a story to me about,
like, how their family was in poverty,
but never tell me, like, okay,
are you saying that the poverty is your diversity?
are you saying.
you have to be very specific about what
you are describing in your diversity statement
and how that has shaped your perspective on the world.
and so if you're gonna tell me that you are
that poverty is your diversity,
you need to describe how that shapes your perspective.
you're gonna tell me that being a
black person is your diversity,
needs to just tell me how that shaped your perspective.
if you're gonna tell me that you're LBGTQ,
if you're gonna tell me that you are,
you went to boarding school, you're.
tell me your veteran,
you are handicapped,
um, you have to make sure it's clear to me
what you're saying makes you diverse.
because a lot of people assume that
just because I'm black
and I'm telling you that I was poor when I was younger,
that you're gonna know what I'm, like,
what I'm describing as my diversity.
and that's a misconception,
um, because both.
both poverty and being black
could be what you're describing as your diverse trait,
and it's confusing if you don't make it clear.
um, so I just wanna make sure that
in your diversity statement,
you have to describe what is making you diverse
and how that specific categorization
shapes your perspective on the world.
I've been seeing a lot of people's diversity statements,
and I really,
just quickly
want to make sure that I help you guys understand
what has to be in your diversity statement.
and your diversity statement and your personal
statement are different for a couple reasons.
your personal statement
has to tell me why you're applying to law school.
it has to tell me what makes you a strong student,
has to give me some background on you
and what got you to your decision to go to law school.
your diversity statement is different
because you need to define what is making you diverse.
so I see a lot of times where people just, like,
describe a story to me about,
like, how their family was in poverty,
but never tell me, like, okay,
are you saying that the poverty is your diversity.
are you saying.
you have to be very specific about what
you are describing in your diversity statement
and how that has shaped your perspective on the world.
and so if you're gonna tell me that you are,
that poverty is your diversity,
you need to describe how that shapes your perspective.
you're gonna tell me that being a
black person is your diversity,
you need to
just tell me how that shaped your perspective.
if you're gonna tell me that you're LBGTQ,
if you're gonna tell me that you are,
you went to boarding school, you're.
tell me your veteran,
you are handicapped,
um, you have to make sure it's
clear to me what you're saying makes you diverse.
because a lot of people assume that
just because I'm black
and I'm telling you that I was poor when I was younger,
that you're gonna know what I'm like,
what I'm describing as my diversity.
and that's a misconception,
because both poverty and being black
could be what you're describing as your diverse trait,
and it's confusing if you don't make it clear.
so I just want to make sure that
in your diversity statement,
you have to describe what is making you diverse
and how that specific categorization
shapes your perspective on the world.